Hello, I'm Maria Madelo with VOA 60 America.
President Barack Obama is proposing new cyber security legislation making it easier...
...for private and public entities to share information with federal officials.
The goal is to prevent cyber threats before they happen.
Mr. Obama said that it is too hard for companies...
...especially those controlling the power grid...
...to share critical security information.
Secretary of State John Kerry traveled to Geneva, Switzerland...
...in a bid to revive stalled talks with Iranian Foreign Minister Javad Zarif...
...regarding Iran's nuclear program.
Kerry said the meeting is a chance for the diplomats to assess where the two sides stand.
An Ohio man with a history of psychiatric illness was arrested...
...for plotting to poison House Speaker John Boehner.
The man was a bartender at an Ohio country club where the Speaker is a member.
That's all for today.
Thanks for watching.